This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。绝对真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇妙的现代世界中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及培养复原力的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。收听《Look Back at It》播客。从 1979 年开始，对我来说那是意义重大的一年。84 年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊聊 80 年代。84 年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《知难而进》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有牌照的专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《知难而进》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20 多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨 20 岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode where we discuss the psychology of our 20s. Today we're talking about procrastination, which is basically our tendency. to delay a task indefinitely, despite knowing that there will be negative consequences for doing so. We delay by doing something to distract us, by preoccupying ourselves with less important things, kind of ignoring the pending deadline all the while knowing that we are most likely going to regret that decision in the future. The amount of literature around this is extensive, and fascinating because I think for a long time, psychologists and researchers were confused as to how
大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们讨论 20 岁心理学的又一期节目。今天我们来聊聊拖延症，这基本上是我们无限期推迟一项任务的倾向，尽管我们知道这样做会有负面后果。我们通过做一些分散注意力的事情来拖延，用不那么重要的事情占据自己，有点像无视即将到来的截止日期，同时心里明知自己在未来极大概率会后悔这个决定。围绕这个主题的文献非常广泛，而且引人入胜，因为我认为在很长一段时间里，心理学家和研究人员都对以下现象感到困惑：
someone could have every intention of doing something, could be motivated, could have a bigger goal that they were working towards, but still actually never do the thing and put something off to the last minute. It's what's known as this intention behavior gap, having every desire to do something. And yet finding that, despite all of that, you can never quite bring. yourself to do it. Maybe you are listening to this episode whilst you avoid your exams or your assignments. Maybe you're putting off studying, you're avoiding those dishes. It might feel productive to get a better understanding of your procrastination by listening to this episode. It might feel important. But that is still procrastination, even if it looks productive, because what we're
一个人可能完全有意愿去做某事，可能有动力，有朝着之努力的更大目标，但实际上却从未采取行动，把事情一拖再拖直到最后一刻。这就是所谓的“意图与行为差距”，明明有着做某事的全部渴望。然而却发现，尽管如此，你还是无法让自己真正去做。也许你正一边听这一期节目，一边逃避你的考试或作业。也许你在推迟学习，在逃避那些盘子。通过听这期节目来更好地理解你的拖延症，可能会让你觉得很有成效。这可能会让你觉得很重要。但那仍然是拖延，即使它看起来很有成效，因为我们正在参与的是
engaging in is avoidance. And a kind of avoidance that could be stemming from a number of factors like academic anxiety and overthinking, perfectionism, feeling like you're not good enough, boredom, a lack of impulse control, negative coping skills. We all do it. Procrastination is a nice kind of guilty pleasure to feel momentarily distracted and able to avoid our stress, even if we know it's going to come back to bite us later on. And I also think it's especially common in our 20s when there always feels like there is like a hundred more urgent tasks to be done or more fun things to be doing, friends to be seeing, online shopping to be done. But whether we're conscious of it or not is another thing. That's the crucial element here. Being aware of why our procrastination
逃避。而这种逃避可能源于多种因素，比如学业焦虑和过度思考、完美主义、觉得自己不够优秀、无聊、冲动控制能力不足、消极的应对技巧。我们所有人都会这样。拖延是一种很好的“罪恶的快乐”，能让人获得片刻的分心并得以逃避压力，哪怕我们知道它以后会反噬我们。而且我也认为这在我们二十多岁时尤为常见，当时总感觉还有成百上千项更紧急的任务要做，或者有更多有趣的事要做、有朋友要见、有网购要清。但我们是否有意识地意识到这一点则是另一回事。这才是这里的关键要素。如果我们想把拖延症控制住，
occurs is important if we want to bring it under control. So today we are going to break down all of the psychology behind why you and I, I do it as well, why we procrastinate, but also much more importantly, I think, how to stop kind of getting in your own way, how to stop letting the tendency to put things off, harm your goals and your dreams. We kind of all have shit to do. We have stuff we want to work towards. And I think wasting your own time isn't going to hurt anyone but yourself. So I really want to provide an overview of how we can manage when we're,
意识到我们的拖延为何发生是很重要的。所以今天我们将剖析你和我（我也会这样）为什么会拖延背后的所有心理学，但更重要的是，我认为，是如何停止阻碍你自己，如何停止让拖延的倾向损害你的目标和梦想。我们大家都有各种各样的事要做。我们有想要为之努力的东西。而且我认为浪费你自己的时间除了伤害你自己之外不会伤害任何人。所以我真的想概述一下，当我们成为
we are chronic procrastinators and actually put some practical strategies in place. All right, so let's start with the basics here. I think the definition of procrastination is a good place to start. We all have some sense of what that is, but basically it's allowing ourselves to shift our focus away from the things that we should be doing by focusing on the things that we could be doing or the things that we want to do. I think procrastination gets blamed for a lot of our time management problems, and it's also often used synonymously with laziness, but they are very different. Lasiness and procrastination are not the same
慢性拖延者时，我们该如何进行管理，并真正落实一些实用的策略。好的，那我们从基础开始吧。我认为从拖延的定义开始是个不错的主意。我们对那是什么都有一些概念，但基本上它就是让我们把注意力从“应该做的事情”上移开，转而关注“可以做的事情”或“想做的事情”。我认为拖延往往被归咎于我们的很多时间管理问题，它也常与懒惰同义，但它们截然不同。懒惰和拖延并非一回事
thing, because laziness involves no intention to do that task at all and real minimal effort upon doing it, but procrastination, when we are procrastinating, we often want to get that thing done. We are very aware of that deadline. We are very aware of the things that we are not doing, but we just can't bring ourselves to do so because of some other reason. And to a certain degree, it's normal to procrastinate, and it can be regarded as kind of a useful way to prioritize between tasks, mainly because we're less likely to procrastinate on tasks that are very, very important and for which failure to do so would be very negative.
因为懒惰意味着根本没有去做那个任务的意图，而且在做的时候付出的努力也极少；但拖延，当我们拖延时，我们通常是想把那件事做好的。我们非常清楚那个截止日期。我们非常清楚那些我们没有在做的事情，但由于某种其他原因，我们就是无法让自己去做。在某种程度上，拖延是正常的，它可以被视为在各项任务之间进行优先级排序的一种有用方式，主要是因为我们不太可能对那些非常非常重要且失败后果非常严重的任务进行拖延。
And also just naturally, I think, procrastination is part of our stress response. We don't like feeling anxious or stressed or overwhelmed. And so avoiding those feelings by avoiding the things on our to-do list, that is a great temporary solution. And I think temporary is the key word here. Procrastination also comes from, you know, just general life stress, being overwhelmed or unfounded negative beliefs we have about ourselves, which we're going to speak about more in a second. However, regardless of the reasons behind this behavior, it can become a problem and it can
而且自然而然地，我认为拖延也是我们压力反应的一部分。我们不喜欢感到焦虑、压力或不知所措。因此，通过逃避待办事项清单上的事情来逃避这些感觉，这是一个极好的权宜之计。而且我认为“权宜之计”是这里的关键词。拖延也源于，你知道的，单纯的生活压力、不知所措，或者我们对自己毫无根据的负面信念，我们稍后会详细讨论这一点。然而，无论这种行为背后的原因是什么，它都可能成为一个问题，并且会
impede our normal functioning. When this happens, procrastination has been found to result in a lot of kind of health problems like stress, anxiety, you know, very mentally, the sense of guilt or a loss of productivity or even feeling kind of an added pressure or an added sense of social disapproval from the people you feel accountable towards. And sometimes it actually causes us to procrastinate more. It makes this tendency, this behavior more chronic. Typically, as we spoke about before, we procrastinate because of aversion, because we want to avoid stress, not by facing it head on or being aware, but by ignoring it. And so that provides momentary relief. We feel that we are safer by just completely ignoring what we need to do than we would be
阻碍我们的正常功能。当这种情况发生时，人们发现拖延会导致很多健康问题，比如压力、焦虑，你知道的，在心理上会产生内疚感、生产力下降，甚至会感到一种来自你觉得需要对之负责的人的额外压力或额外的社会反对感。有时它实际上会导致我们更加拖延。它使这种倾向、这种行为变得更加慢性。通常，正如我们之前所讨论的，我们因为厌恶而拖延，因为我们想要逃避压力，不是通过正面迎接它或保持觉察，而是通过忽视它。因此，这提供了片刻的 relief（解脱）。我们觉得通过完全忽视我们需要做的事情，会比我们
if we had to really focus and concentrate on what may seem quite impossible. So that actually makes the cycle especially vicious. So in the immediate present, if you're putting off, you know, writing that essay or doing your taxes, I don't know, you are delaying the oncoming stress. And we know from very basic principles of reinforcement that when we're rewarded for something, such as avoiding something terrible, we tend to do it again. And that is kind of precisely why procrastination tends to not be a one-off behavior, but almost a chronic habit. There's an important distinction, I think, between what I would call work or task-based procrastination, maybe a better word for it is like practical procrastination, and then emotional procrastination. So I think task-based
不得不真正把注意力和精神集中在那些看似不可能完成的事情上时要安全得多。所以这实际上让这个循环变得格外恶性。因此，在眼下的当下，如果你在拖延（你知道的）写那篇论文或报税，我不知道，你就是在推迟即将到来的压力。我们从强化的最基本原则中了解到，当我们因某事而获得奖励时，比如逃避了某些糟糕的事情，我们往往会再次这样做。这正是为什么拖延往往不是一次性行为，而几乎是一种慢性习惯的确切原因。我认为，在我称之为“工作或基于任务的拖延”（也许更好的词是“实用性拖延”）与“情绪性拖延”之间，存在一个重要的区别。所以我认为基于任务的
procrastination is what we typically think of, you know, putting off paying your parking fines, delaying, studying, waiting until the last minute to submit that work deadline. And I think the area where we talk about practical procrastination the most is when it comes to our academics. And that's because we have a lot of opportunities to procrastinate with fewer overt consequences. You know, if you miss a really important work deadline, that's your job on the line, right? You could be fired. The stakes are super high. But if you don't do your laundry, you know, it's not the end of the world.
拖延是我们通常想到的，你知道的，推迟交停车罚单、拖延学习、拖到最后一刻才提交工作截止日期。我认为我们讨论实用性拖延最多的领域是在学业方面。那是因为我们有很多拖延的机会，而明显的后果却更少。你知道的，如果你错过了一个非常重要的工作截止日期，那就是你的工作危在旦夕，对吧？你可能会被解雇。利害关系超级高。但如果你不洗衣服，你知道的，那也不是世界末日。
Studying is so task-based, so repetitive, but the consequences are also so individual. And we often feel like we will have time to make up for it when we're. kind of in that studying mentality. So it is the area we see it the most. Unfortunately, for us though, procrastinators have been found to receive worse grades than non-procrastinators. In one study they did in the late 90s, what they saw when they looked at final exam scores is that amongst people who didn't procrastinate or at least didn't say they procrastinate and the people who did, there was this huge variation in the marks that they were receiving. So I think that negative association between procrastination and academic performance is not just one that we see in academic studies and in articles and in research.
学习是如此基于任务、如此重复，但后果也极其个人化。而且当我们处于那种学习的心态时，我们经常觉得我们会有时间去弥补。所以这是我们看到它最多的领域。不幸的是，对我们而言，人们发现拖延者的成绩比非拖延者更差。在 90 年代末进行的一项研究中，他们在查看期末考试分数时发现，在不拖延的人（或至少自称不拖延的人）与拖延的人之间，他们所获得的成绩存在着巨大的差异。所以我认为拖延与学业表现之间的这种负面联系，不仅仅是我们从学术研究、文章和研究中看到的。
It's also one that we see in our own lives. You know, when we have poor academic grades as well, we also report higher levels of stress and poor kind of self-worth and increasing sense that we are failures rather than understanding that this behavior is sometimes not always in our control. So that is task-based procrastination, but emotional procrastination is a little bit different. And it's kind of usually referred to in the context of emotional avoidance, unavailability, conflict aversion. Really at the end of the day, procrastination is more about managing our emotions than it is about managing our time. And the area that we experience the biggest emotions is generally in our relationships.
这也是我们在自己的生活中看到的。你知道的，当我们学业成绩不佳时，我们也会报告更高水平的压力、更差的自我价值感，以及一种不断增长的“我们是失败者”的感觉，而不是去理解这种行为有时并不完全在我们的控制之下。这就是基于任务的拖延，但情绪性拖延则有些不同。它通常是在情感回避、情感不可用、冲突厌恶的语境下被提及的。归根结底，拖延更多的是关于管理我们的情绪，而不是管理我们的时间。而我们体验到最大情绪的领域通常是在我们的关系中。
I always think of the example of someone maybe messaging, you something really confrontational and you put it off for days until you're ready to reply or you completely, you know, avoid a friend instead of talking about something that you know needs to be addressed. That is emotional procrastination. You're putting off an important task indefinitely knowing there might be consequences. Sometimes what we're feeling or anticipating can be so intense, that sense of someone being upset at us or maybe being, mad, us being rejected, that is so intense that we busy ourselves with anything but to prevent having to experience what might be really uncomfortable and awkward. We all know that doesn't work
我总是想起这样的例子：有人可能会给你发一些非常具有对抗性的信息，而你却把回复推迟了好几天，直到你准备好为止；或者你完全（你知道的）避开一个朋友，而不是去谈论一件你知道需要解决的事情。这就是情绪性拖延。你无限期地推迟一项重要的任务，明知可能会有后果。有时我们所感受到的或预料到的东西可能非常强烈，那种别人对我们感到不满、或者可能生气、被我们拒绝的感觉是如此强烈，以至于我们用任何事情来让自己忙碌，就是为了避免去体验那些可能真的很不舒服和尴尬的事情。我们都知道这行不通
though. That's the nature of procrastination. There will always be negative consequences down the line. But I think our tendency to do this explains why sometimes it doesn't even feel in our control, even if we want to reply to that text message, even if we're prepared to have hard conversations, it still comes from a place of not only emotional avoidance of stress, but also kind of the prioritisation of short-term mood repair over the long-term pursuit of an intended action. So basically, these researchers put it really, really well. I'm just going to copy and paste their words here because I think it's the best way to put it. When we procrastinate, what we're more focused on is the immediate urgency of managing our negative mood rather than getting on with the
然而。这就是拖延的本质。未来总是会有负面后果。但我认为我们这样做的倾向解释了为什么有时它甚至感觉不在我们的控制之中，即使我们想回复那条短信，即使我们准备好进行艰难的对话，它仍然源于不仅对压力的情感回避，还源于将短期情绪修复置于长期追求预期行动之上的倾向。基本上，这些研究人员把这一点说得真的非常非常棒。我打算在这里直接复制粘贴他们的原话，因为我认为这是最好的表达方式。当我们拖延时，我们更关注的是管理负面情绪的直接紧迫性，而不是继续推进
task. And a lot of that comes from the development and the reliance on pretty negative coping skills. And procrastination just tends to elevate those. When we know we have something pressing to do, procrastination kind of makes us do a few sneaky things, things that we might not even realize we're doing, employing these habits not just to prevent us from starting or completing a task, but also allowing us to ignore any sign or reminder of it. So that includes kind of even avoiding the location where the task takes place, maybe avoiding your uni campus or avoiding going into the office, denying the consequences of not completing the task in, you know, engaging in a bit of delusional thinking, the classic one being, you know, I'll do it on the weekend. I can do it tomorrow,
任务。这其中很大一部分来自于对相当消极的应对技能的发展和依赖。而拖延往往会加剧这些技能。当我们知道自己有紧迫的事情要做时，拖延会让我们做一些鬼祟的事情，这些事情甚至可能在我们自己都没意识到的时候就在做了，采用这些习惯不仅是为了阻止我们开始或完成一项任务，也是为了让我们能够忽略它的任何迹象或提醒。这甚至包括避开任务发生的地点，也许是避开你的大学校园，或者避免去办公室，否认不完成任务的后果（你知道的），陷入一点妄想式的思维中，最典型的一句就是（你知道的）：“我周末再做。”“我明天可以做。”
which, let's be honest, we rarely actually do that. Blaming external factors for not doing the task, like, oh, I had to call my mom, I had to pick up that extra shift, my friends really needed to see me, and also something called valorization. Now, this is an interesting one for us in our 20s, because although not many of us know the word for it, I think we all somewhat do it. So valorization, involves elevating the satisfaction of doing one task as a reason to not do the other, or making it seem like the other thing you did is more important as an excuse. For example, this is the one I see all the time, also the one I use all the time. Like, I'm only going to be young once, so it's really important for me to go to that party.
说实话，我们很少真正那样做。把未能完成任务归咎于外部因素，比如，“噢，我得给我妈打电话”、“我得去加个班”、“我的朋友们真的需要见我”，还有一种东西叫做“自我价值美化”（valorization）。现在，这对我们这群二十多岁的人来说是一个有趣的现象，因为尽管我们当中没有多少人知道这个词，但我认为我们所有人都在某种程度上这样做过。所以，自我价值美化，涉及到把完成某项任务的满足感拔高，以此作为不去做另一项任务的借口，或者把另一件你做过的事说得更重要，以此当成借口。例如，这是我经常看到的一种情况，也是我一直在使用的一种情况。比如：“我年轻只有一次，所以去参加那个派对对我很重要。”
It's really important for me to go see my friends rather than finish my assignment because I'm in my 20s. I'm young, that's important to me. We place a higher value on the behavior we know we probably shouldn't be doing that's not productive. To feel better about not completing the thing that we know we needed to do. That pattern of avoidance, especially in regards to stress, not wanting to actually acknowledge just how much we need to do, how overwhelming it's going to be to start, how anxious we're going to feel once we confront the actual problem, that's one explanation. That's one opinion on procrastination. Boredom is obviously another.
“对我来说，去见朋友比写完作业更重要，因为我正处于二十多岁。我很年轻，这对我来说很重要。”我们把更高的价值放在那个我们明知不该做、没有生产力的行为上。为了让自己对没有完成那件我们明知该做的事情感觉好一些。这种逃避模式，尤其是关于压力、不愿意真正承认我们需要做多少事情、开始会有多崩溃、当我们面对真正的问题时我们会感到多焦虑，这是一种解释。这是关于拖延的一种观点。无聊显然是另一种。
Sometimes the things we need to do are just like, they're just not fun. And we know that our brains like novelty, they like stimulation, they like doing things that it enjoys. So if that pressing task you need to do isn't providing that stimulation, we're not going to want to do it. No one likes having to clean their car or do their taxes, which is often why we put those off for so long. for the simple fact that they are boring and they are tedious. So why not, you know, scroll TikTok or Instagram instead, things that will immediately give us that dopamine hit. And that links to what is known as the pleasure principle. So the pleasure principle is a Freudian idea and it has a lot to do with impulse control. What this principle argues is that each of us has this inherent
有时我们需要做的事情就是……就是一点也不好玩。我们知道我们的大脑喜欢新鲜感，喜欢刺激，喜欢做它觉得有趣的事情。所以如果那个你需要做的紧迫任务并没有提供那种刺激，我们就不会想去做它。没有人喜欢打扫汽车或报税，这也是为什么我们常常把这些事情推迟那么久的原因，原因很简单，因为它们既无聊又枯燥。所以为什么不（你知道的）转而刷 TikTok 或 Instagram 呢，那些能立即给我们多巴胺刺激的事情。这就连接到了所谓的“快乐原则”。所以快乐原则是一个弗洛伊德式的观点，它与冲动控制有很大关系。这个原则认为，我们每个人都有一种内在的
desire to pursue immediate gratification and reward. We, want to have fun right now. We want that new item of clothing right now without having to say for it. We want that sweet treat. We want that nap. And sometimes we don't have the cognitive restraint to tell ourselves no, because it's so appealing and it's so instantaneous. We're kind of like little kids in that sense. And so we sacrifice long-term payoff for short-term pleasure and satisfaction. It's why we often see that people who are more likely to procrastinate have poorer impulse control because A, they can't ignore the appeal of what's right in front of them, and B, often the tasks that we most want to avoid are the ones that are going to take the most effort,
渴望，去追求即时的满足感和奖励。我们……想要立刻获得快乐。我们想要立刻拥有那件新衣服，而不需要为此存钱。我们想要那个甜品。我们想要小睡一会儿。有时我们没有认知上的克制力来对自己说“不”，因为它是如此诱人且如此即时。从某种意义上说，我们就像小孩子。因此，我们为了短期的快乐和满足而牺牲了长期的回报。这就是为什么我们经常看到，更容易拖延的人通常冲动控制能力更差，因为 A，他们无法忽视眼前诱惑的吸引力，B，通常我们最想逃避的任务往往是那些需要付出最多精力、
time, emotional energy, and all of that investment is going to come before we actually get the satisfaction or the reward for it being completed. So why wait for that bigger payoff when you could have a dozen? smaller payoffs in the short run. We can't control that impulse. So we procrastinate and we put things off leading to that negative cycle whereby inevitably the more we distract ourselves, the worse the situation becomes, the less time you have. And so you feel a greater need to procrastinate. Your impulsive behaviors become stronger and you're kind of stuck. Some people with poor impulse control also have increased risk-taking behaviors. And so they just enjoy the pressure and the
时间、情感能量的任务，而所有这些投入都要在我们真正获得它完成后的满足感或奖励之前发生。所以，既然你可以在短期内得到一打较小的回报，为什么还要等待那个更大的回报呢？我们无法控制那种冲动。于是我们拖延，把事情往后推，从而导致那个负面循环：不可避免地，我们越分散注意力，情况就越糟糕，你剩下的时间就越少。因此你会感到更大的拖延需求。你的冲动行为变得更强烈，你就这样卡住了。有些冲动控制能力差的人也会增加冒险行为，因此他们只是享受把事情拖到最后一刻所带来的压力和
energy of leaving things to the last minute. They kind of live for that adrenaline. They find it makes them more productive. And once they get used to that feeling, the more they're going to do it. The more they can't complete a task without that rush and that added risk or possibility of maybe I won't get it done in time. That's exciting. If you're not getting the motivation externally, that internal anxiety will definitely do it. You do not feel like you can do the thing. You do not feel like you can do the task unless it's so immediately urgent that you just cannot put it off for any longer. I know so many people like this, one of my friends was actually asking me about this the other day.
能量。他们某种程度上靠那种肾上腺素过活。他们发现这让他们更有成效。一旦他们习惯了那种感觉，他们就会做得更多。如果没有那种冲动、额外的风险或“也许我无法按时完成”的可能性，他们就无法完成任务。这很刺激。如果你没有获得外部的动力，那种内部的焦虑绝对会促使你行动。你觉得自己无法完成那件事。除非情况已经紧急到你再也无法拖延哪怕一分一秒，否则你根本不会觉得自己能搞定那个任务。我认识很多这样的人，我的一个朋友前几天还专门问我这件事。
And I said, you know, you like the adrenaline. You like the stress. Those are the conditions. you've told yourself you're most productive under, and so now you don't want to do anything differently. Okay, so we've covered three unique explanations for your procrastination so far, but there's one that we haven't covered, and I actually think it's the most important.
我说，你知道的，你喜欢肾上腺素。你喜欢压力。那是你告诉自己的、你最高效的条件，所以现在你不想做任何改变。好了，到目前为止，我们已经介绍了关于你拖延的三个独特解释，但还有一个我们没有涵盖，而我实际上认为它是最重要的。
If you are a perfectionist, if you are an overachiever, an overthinker, I think this one will definitely apply to you. So we're going to talk about that and a lot more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
如果你是一个完美主义者，如果你是一个过度成就者、过度思考者，我想这一点绝对适用于你。所以在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论这个以及更多内容。《2%》。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在奇妙的现代世界中培养复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们真的相信种子油本质上会导致炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。那就是 T-W-O-Persent。还记得黛安·罗斯在 VMA 上双击（亲吻）莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crazy. crack.
乔治·布什和莉儿·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，滔滔不绝地谈论 80 年代的快克（可卡因）。需要说明的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为疯狂的
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
快克。我随时准备在白天谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在台面上了。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《知难而进》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我在谈论
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了样东西。而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢。史蒂芬·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
因为你觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要，还是你当一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
在我的新播客《知难而进》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeart Radio App。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的法律诉讼来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini.
你这么多次伪造了这个特定的测试，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，那个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。这还没结束，直到正义
is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You want to know the biggest reason people procrastinate? It's to do with perfectionism, a fear of failure of not living up to your potential. This seems kind of counterintuitive. Surely if you are a perfectionist, someone who sets really high standards for themselves, you know, procrastination would not typically be a behavior.
在亚利桑那州得到伸张。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。你想知道人们拖延的最大原因是什么吗？这与完美主义有关，源于对失败的恐惧、对未能达到潜力的恐惧。这听起来有点违反直觉。当然，如果你是一个完美主义者，一个为自己设定极高标准的人，你知道的，拖延通常不会是一种
that you're engaging in because you want to be your best and procrastination takes away from that. But actually it's that excessive focus on being the best, that pickiness, that preoccupation with flawlessness that makes perfectionists more likely to procrastinate. And that's because they face this kind of internal dissonance. If it's not going to be perfect, why should I try? What do I even start? The mountain just seems so much. if you have these kind of standards for yourself.
你会有意去做的行为，因为你想做到最好，而拖延会剥夺这一点。但实际上，正是那种对成为最好的过度关注、那种挑剔、对完美无瑕的执迷，才使得完美主义者更有可能拖延。这是因为他们面临着一种内在的失调：如果不能做到完美，我为什么还要尝试？我为什么要开始？如果你为自己设定了这样的标准，那座山看起来就太高了。
Perfectionists also become obsessed with really small, minute details and sometimes a sense of procedure. And we can see how that relates to procrastination where we go, okay, I'll start this essay, but first I just need to make sure that my room is clean, or I need to get this one other thing done, or I need to get a snack, otherwise I won't be able to focus. Those details for most of us shouldn't be. as compelling as they are, but when we're a perfectionist, it's really hard to ignore them.
完美主义者也会对非常微小、细枝末节的细节产生强迫症，有时甚至执着于某种程序。我们可以看到这与拖延的关系，我们会想：“好吧，我要开始写这篇论文了，但首先我需要确保我的房间是干净的，或者我需要把这件别的事情做完，或者我需要吃点零食，否则我将无法集中注意力。”对于我们大多数人来说，那些细节本不该像它们表现得那么引人注目，但当我们是一个完美主义者时，真的很难忽视它们。
And so if you find yourself relating to that description and struggling with procrastination, you may tend to feel really overwhelmed when you think about the amount of work that's going to be required to produce the results that you want for yourself. I had a friend who once said to me, once I start to do something, not only does it feel more real, but I know it's going to take a lot of trial and error. And that's the thing I can't cope with, not the work, but the mistakes I know that I'm going to make. So why don't I just not try it all? And then if I fail, I fail because I didn't try, not because I'm lacking some other ability, not because I'm not smart, not because I'm not perfect. Obviously, there is some very
所以，如果你发现自己与这种描述产生共鸣并且正在与拖延症作斗争，那么当你想到要产生你想要的结果所需的工作量时，你可能会感到非常不知所措。我有个朋友曾对我说：“一旦我开始做某事，它不仅感觉更真实了，而且我知道这需要大量的试错。而这是我无法应付的事情，不是工作本身，而是我知道我会犯的错误。所以我为什么不索性不尝试呢？这样如果我失败了，我的失败是因为我没有尝试，而不是因为我缺乏某种能力，不是因为我不够聪明，不是因为我不够完美。”显然，这其中存在着一种非常
deep irony apparent in that, but that is what perfectionism is. It's irrational. So, According to one psychologist, overplanning is a pretty considerable tell-tale sign that your procrastination is not laziness, is not poor time management. It's actually perfectionism in disguise. So her name is Dr. Shield and she says that perfectionists often want to control every variable and anticipate every potential issue before taking action. The problem is that when we overplan, that plan is almost never good enough. So you might write essay structure after essay structure, draft after draft, plan your day over and over again.
深刻的讽刺，但这就是完美主义。它是非理性的。所以，根据一位心理学家的说法，过度规划是一个相当显着的迹象，表明你的拖延不是懒惰，不是糟糕的时间管理。它实际上是伪装成完美主义的产物。所以她叫盾牌博士（Dr. Shield），她说完美主义者在采取行动之前，往往希望控制每一个变量并预测每一个潜在问题。问题是，当我们过度规划时，那个计划几乎永远不够好。所以你可能会写了一篇又一篇的论文结构，一份又一份的草稿，一遍又一遍地规划你的一天。
And it's going to create this endless cycle of brainstorming, planning, and overthinking. And so we never actually feel confident enough to get started until we believe that it's going to be perfect with what we have in mind. And I think that kind of that that aiming for perfection, that's unrealistic. for anybody, no matter how skilled they are, but we hold ourselves to such a high standard that we can't see that. To expand on that, perfectionists are often also overachievers. And so they commit to too many tasks. They fail to prioritize properly. They genuinely just do not have enough time. They don't have enough time. And maybe that overcommitment is also subconsciously a way to offer themselves a distraction.
这会造成一个无休止的头脑风暴、规划和过度思考的循环。因此，在我们相信它能达到我们心中的完美之前，我们永远不会觉得有足够的信心开始。我认为那种追求完美的想法，对任何人来说都是不切实际的，无论他们多么熟练，但我们对自己抱持着如此高的标准，以至于我们看不到这一点。延伸开来，完美主义者通常也是过度成就者。所以他们承担了太多的任务。他们未能进行正确的优先级排序。他们真心只是没有足够的时间。他们没有足够的时间。也许这种过度承诺也是潜意识里为自己提供干扰的一种方式。
But it's also because they just can't say no, they need to be the best, they need to do everything. So that leaves no time to do just one thing really well. So this whole group of tendencies, this combination of perfectionism, of overthinking, overachieving a fear of failure, that shows up a lot in our academic performance. So according to some early researchers on this idea, academic procrastination has been correlated to what they call performance avoidance orientation. So this is kind of like a personality trait, a personality orientation is what we would call it. And people who have this, they're very much concerned with avoiding failure, but mainly avoiding failure in front of others. They're very
但这也是因为他们就是无法拒绝，他们需要成为最好的，他们需要把每件事都做好。这就导致没有时间把仅仅一件事做好。所以这一整套倾向，这种完美主义、过度思考、过度成就、对失败的恐惧的结合，在我们的学业表现中大量出现。根据早期研究这一概念的一些研究人员的说法，学业拖延与他们所谓的“表现回避倾向”呈正相关。所以这有点像一种人格特质，我们称之为“人格倾向”。而拥有这种特质的人，非常关注如何避免失败，但主要是避免在其他人面前失败。他们非常
extrinsically motivated by a fear of poor performance, by what other people might think of them if they see that and also this like innate comparison between themselves and others as well that they really struggle with these students procrastinated as a result because they don't want to look incompetent they don't want to demonstrate any flaws so they adopt a facade of competence but also really deeply struggle with a feeling of of lacking self-worth maybe of imposter syndrome and of course chronic procrastination. And we've talked about this briefly in terms of people who like to wait to the last minute to get that rush, to get that adrenaline spike.
受到对表现不佳的恐惧、别人看到后可能会如何看待他们的外在动机的驱使，以及他们与他人之间真正难以克服的这种内在比较。因此，这些学生由于不希望显得无能而拖延，他们不想表现出任何瑕疵，所以他们披上了能力的外衣，但内心深处却极力挣扎于缺乏自我价值感、可能存在的冒名顶替综合症，以及当然还有慢性拖延症。我们之前简短地讨论过那些喜欢等到最后一刻来获得那种冲动、获得肾上腺素飙升的人。
But it actually has its own terms specifically applied for people who are studying for students. It's known as student syndrome. This phenomenon where we wait and we wait to apply ourselves until we really can't wait any longer to leverage that sense of urgency. We know that this behavior hurts us. we've seen the outcomes, more stress, poorer grades, missed deadlines, but our anxiety and our perfectionism, it really doesn't care. We've trained our brains to respond to pressure in a different way.
但它实际上有它自己的专门针对正在学习的学生术语。这被称为“学生综合症”。这种现象表现为：我们等待并等待着付出努力，直到我们真的再也无法等待，去利用那种紧迫感。我们知道这种行为会伤害我们。我们已经看到了结果：更多的压力、更差的成绩、错过的截止日期，但我们的焦虑和完美主义真的不在乎。我们已经训练我们的大脑以不同的方式对压力做出反应。
And we kind of cannot bear the prospect of not doing our best. And so we engage in this kind of negative coping mechanism, this way of avoiding that impending sense of stress, of being overwhelmed, of being anxious about what this thing could mean for our sense of self-worth. That's kind of the simplest way of putting it. There's also this whole body of research dedicated to how we feel after we procrastinate. Spoiler alert, it's not great. The thoughts we have about procrastination typically actually exacerbate our distress and that contributes to, as we know, further procrastination. So it seems like we're kind of stuck here. And maybe that is the place you're in now.
而且我们简直无法忍受“未能做到最好”的前景。因此，我们陷入了这种负面应对机制，这种逃避迫在眉睫的压力感、不知所措感、对这件事可能对我们的自尊意味着什么的焦虑感的方式。这可以说是最简单的说法了。还有一整套研究致力于探讨我们在拖延之后的感受。剧透预警，感觉并不好。我们关于拖延的想法实际上通常会加剧我们的痛苦，正如我们所知，这会导致进一步的拖延。所以看起来我们好像被困在这里了。也许这就是你现在的处境。
You're feeling like no matter what you do, no matter how motivated you are, no matter how much you tell yourself, it is going to be different. Suddenly you get to the point of not being able to actually, you know, go through with that. You get stuck in the loop. And I think that's what I'm here to help with, what I really want to discuss in this next kind of segment of this episode, because it's all great to know why, but to know how to fix it is probably more important. So, let's discuss kind of six practical tips to overcome your procrastination. First of all, chunking. So chunking is normally used to describe a specific way of learning in psychology,
你觉得无论你做什么，无论你有多大动力，无论你对自己说多少次这次会有所不同。突然之间，你到了无法真正（你知道的）把事情贯彻到底的地步。你陷入了这个死循环。我想这就是我来这里的目的，也是我真正想在这期节目的下一个环节中讨论的内容，因为知道“为什么”固然很好，但知道“如何解决”可能更重要。那么，让我们讨论克服拖延症的六个实用技巧。首先，分块法（chunking）。所以在心理学中，分块法通常用来描述一种特定的学习方法
where we break down information into smaller pieces in order to remember it. But when it comes to procrastination, this habit involves breaking down what feels like an impossible task into smaller, itty-bitty tasks, little activities. and the premise of that is super simple. When we break something down, a problem, a task, things on our to-do list, whatever it is, it feels less impossible. It feels like there is less pressure on us to get it all done right now, as soon as possible, all in one go.
我们将信息拆分成更小的部分以便记住它。但当谈到拖延时，这个习惯包括将看似不可能完成的任务拆分成更小、微不足道的任务和小活动。其前提非常简单。当我们把某事、一个问题、一项任务、待办事项列表上的事情等拆分时，它就显得没那么不可能了。我们感觉现在就得尽快、一次性把它全部完成的压力变小了。
And so we manage our time better. We manage our expectations better. We manage our stress better. I used to do this when I was at uni. I would break down writing an essay into writing only five smaller paragraphs. So instead of feeling like I had to write 3,000 words all in one day, I would be like, okay, you just have to write 500 words in the next two hours. And that's your task.
因此我们能更好地管理时间。我们能更好地管理期望。我们能更好地管理压力。我上大学时就经常这么做。我会把写一篇论文拆分成只写五个较小的段落。所以，与其觉得我必须在一天内写完3000字，我会想，好吧，你在接下来的两个小时里只需要写500字。这就是你的任务。
Don't think about the bigger thing. Don't think about the thing that's like kind of the cloud above your head. Just think about this one small activity that's super doable. Writing 500 words could do that in like an hour and chunk the task down. While you're doing that as well, also engage in what we call positive self-reinforcement. often the reason we can't get our impulses under control to distract ourselves to do something else is because when we try and force ourselves to do something, we do so in an environment of deprivation. Think about it in this way. You have this huge essay, I know I'm using this academic example quite a bit,
不要去想那件大事。不要去想那种悬在你头顶上的阴云似的事情。只需去想这一个超级容易完成的小活动。写500字大约一个小时就能搞定，并把任务切成小块。在做这件事的同时，还要进行我们所谓的积极自我强化。通常我们无法控制冲动去分心做别的事的原因是，当我们试图强迫自己做某事时，我们是在剥夺的环境中这样做的。换个角度想想。你有这么长的一篇论文，我知道我经常用这个学术例子，
but I think it's most relevant. And so you have this essay, you force yourself to sit down at a desk and not move until it's done. or you keep thinking about the things you need to do is really boring or tedious. When we have that mindset, it's going to be harder to complete what needs to be completed because you're not giving yourself the reward your brain needs to keep going. You're not giving it that stimulation. And we talked about this when we discussed the pleasure principle. Our brains are always going to want to do the activity that is more fun. But if you give it a little treat, a little variable reward,
但我认为这最相关。所以你有一篇论文，你强迫自己坐在桌前，不完成就不准动；或者你一直想着你需要做的事情真的很无聊或很乏味。当我们有这种心态时，要完成需要完成的事情就会变得更加困难，因为你没有给自己大脑继续坚持下去所需的奖励。你没有给它那种刺激。我们在讨论享乐原则时谈过这一点。我们的大脑总是更想做那些更有趣的活动。但如果你给它一点小奖励、一点可变的奖励，
at different intervals, it's going to remain focused because it doesn't feel as deprived. And when it feels deprived, it's going to search for external stimulation. So by giving it that instead, you are able to bring your attention, your focus, back into control. Phone breaks are a classic one, giving yourself five minutes of TikTok or Instagram time every hour. It also kind of makes it feel a little bit more special than when we're just kind of constantly flooding our brains with this like instant gratification. I used to also use gummy bears on my textbook. So on each page, I'd put a gummy bear. And when I finished it, I would get the gummy bear. I know it's kind of funny, but it really did work because it like kept me looking forward. It kept me being like, okay,
在不同的时间间隔给予它，它就会保持专注，因为它不会感到被剥夺。而当它感到被剥夺时，它就会去寻找外部刺激。因此，通过转而给予它奖励，你能够重新控制你的注意力和专注力。玩手机就是个经典的例子，每小时给自己五分钟刷TikTok或Instagram的时间。这也让它感觉比我们不断用这种即时满足感来轰动大脑时要稍微特别一点。我以前还会在教科书上放小熊软糖。所以每一页上我都会放一颗小熊软糖。当我读完那一页时，我就可以吃这颗小熊软糖。我知道这听起来有点搞笑，但它真的很管用，因为它让我有所期待。它让我觉得，好吧，
this isn't just like some exhausting, monotonous, never-ending task. There is reward built into this kind of structure. So this is all about getting your mind to not fear moments of hard work, to not fear moments of dedicated effort because you are showing your brain that's the sacrifice of doing something tough is not going to come without reward. We also cannot overestimate the influence of social accountability. According to studies conducted and published in the Harvard Business Review, when other people are watching us, we feel that what we are doing is magnified. and that can fuel our motivation.
这不仅仅是一些令人筋疲力尽、单调乏味、永无止境的任务。这种结构中内置了奖励。所以这一切都是为了让你的大脑不再害怕努力工作的时刻，不再害怕专注付出的时刻，因为你在向大脑表明，做艰难事情的付出并非没有回报。我们也不能高估社会责任感的影响。根据《哈佛商业评论》发表的研究，当有其他人看着我们时，我们会觉得我们正在做的事情被放大了，这可以激发我们的动力。
It's kind of similar to the spotlight effect. Now, obviously this is a double-sided coin because friends, co-workers, partners can sometimes be a distraction if they're in the room with us. But also when we feel like we are being watched or observed, we are more likely to act in accordance with what we want our best selves to be doing, what we want ourselves to look like for others. We want to look focused.
这有点类似于聚光灯效应。当然，这是一把双刃剑，因为如果朋友、同事或伴侣和我们呆在同一个房间里，有时他们会成为一种干扰。但同样，当我们觉得被注视或观察时，我们更有可能按照我们希望成为的最好自己的样子去行事，按照我们希望在他人面前呈现的样子去行事。我们希望看起来专注。
We want to look like we have a good work ethic. So that external pressure or perhaps kind of implicit expectation keeps us from actively procrastinating. Study groups are great for this studying in public places like at a public library. Also amazing. There's always onlookers, bystanders walking behind you. And even more practically for when you maybe need the silence, you want to be alone, but you still want that social accountability. There's a series on YouTube called Study With Me by this account called Merv's Study Corner. That is so motivating. you so she does these like videos where she's like study with me for 12 hours study with me for six hours
我们希望看起来有良好的职业道德。因此，这种外部压力或某种隐含的期望使我们免于积极拖延。学习小组对这种在公共场所（如公共图书馆）学习的方式非常棒。同样令人惊叹。总会有旁观者、路人在你身后走过。对于更实际的情况，比如当你可能需要安静、想独处，但仍希望有这种社会责任感时，YouTube上有一个名为“与我一起学习”（Study With Me）的系列节目，由一个叫Merv's Study Corner的账号制作。那个节目太有动力了，她会做一些这样的视频，比如“与我一起学习12小时”、“与我一起学习6小时”，
I used to love them you can have it on in the background and seeing this standard that someone else is setting for themselves using them as a model for your own behavior I think keeps you focused and allows you to avoid the temptation of distraction social accountability we have social brains we are social creatures it really does work so my next tip is specifically for my perfectionist and my thinkers, my overachievers out there, and that is to apply the 80-20 rule. Now, this was originally used as a phrase in a lot of like diet, nutritional weight loss communities, but I've seen it adapted to workplaces, to personal goals, to relationships, everything in between. The premise is that when we hold ourselves to the standard that we need to be 100% perfect, 100% productive, 100% free of
我以前很喜欢它们。你可以把它当成背景播放，看着别人为自己设定的标准，并以他们为榜样来约束自己的行为，我认为这能让你保持专注，并避免被分心诱惑。社会责任感，我们拥有社会性的大脑，我们是社会性的生物，这确实管用。所以我的下一个建议专门针对那些完美主义者、思考者和追求卓越的人，那就是应用80-20法则。最初，这个短语被广泛用于许多节食、营养和减肥社群中，但我看到它被改编应用到了职场、个人目标、人际关系以及介于两者之间的方方面面。其前提是，当我们要求自己必须100%完美、100%高产、100%时刻摆脱
procrastination all of the time, we are rarely going to be successful. And so that inability to hold ourselves to that standard is going to create a negative cycle or spiral of kind of putting off the task again and again in the future because we're fearful of not meeting that expectation. Instead, aim for 80-20. 80% perfect, 20% almost there. 20% room for error. 20% you know, it's not great.
拖延时，我们很少能取得成功。因此，无法达到这一标准将产生一种恶性循环或螺旋，因为我们害怕达不到预期，从而在未来一次又一次地推迟任务。相反，目标定为80-20。80%完美，20%差不多就行。20%留有出错的空间。20%你知道，虽然不是最好，
but it's done. You know, 80% is still exceptional. It's still an A. It's still a high distinction. It's still 80% of the task done compared to 0% if we were to get stuck in the overplanning procrastination loop. And you've also minimised some of the stress of being perfect in the process. So 80-20 rule, if you are a perfectionist, will save you so much time, so much anxiety. Chronic procrastinators also benefit from setting false deadlines for themselves. if you know something needs to be done by the fifth of the month, put it in your diary that the real deadline is the first and push forward with that deadline in your mind.
但总算完成了。你知道，80%依然很优秀。它依然是个A，依然是高等级，相比于陷入过度规划的拖延循环而导致0%的完成度，它已经完成了任务的80%。而且在这个过程中，你也减轻了追求完美的一些压力。所以，如果你是个完美主义者，80-20法则会为你节省大量时间和焦虑。惯性拖延者也能从为自己设定虚假截止日期中受益。如果你知道某件事必须在当月5号前完成，就在日程表里把真正的截止日期写成1号，并在心里按这个截止日期去推进。
So they did a study on this in 2002, and it indicated that students who are aware that they have a tendency to procrastinate and they respond by setting what we call self-binding deadlines are more likely to get the task done before it's due. So these self-imposed deadlines, they are correlated with better performance, compared to those who just use the external deadline as their main marker. I know that that might feel like it's adding an additional time commitment, an additional time
他们在2002年对此做过一项研究，表明那些意识到自己有拖延倾向并通过设定所谓的自我约束截止日期来应对的学生，更有可能在到期前完成任务。因此，这些自我强加的截止日期与更好的表现呈正相关，而那些仅仅将外部截止日期作为主要标志的人则不然。我知道这可能让人感觉增加额外的时间承诺和额外的时间
constraint, but what it really does for you is allow you to prepare for a date closer in the future and then provides you with a buffer for that procrastination you know might take place. Obviously not for everyone, especially if you know you're going to ignore that binding deadline anyways. But for some people, particularly those who like the rush of the last, minute urgency and crunch time, but want to avoid the negative consequences of that. You can kind of engage in a little bit of self-delusion here. That might be part of the solution for you. Finally, and I feel like this is so obvious that it goes without saying, but please remove those distractions. Corporate number one is always going to be your phone.
限制，但它真正为你做的是让你能够为更近的未来某个日期做好准备，然后为你知道可能会发生的拖延提供一个缓冲。当然这并不适合所有人，特别是如果你知道自己无论如何都会忽略这个有约束力的截止日期的话。但对于某些人，尤其是那些喜欢最后一刻的紧迫感和冲刺阶段，但又想避免其负面影响的人来说，你可以进行一点自我欺骗。这或许能成为你的部分解决方案。最后，我觉得这太显而易见了，甚至无需多言，但请移除那些干扰。头号大敌永远是你的手机。
And I don't mean remove distractions by like just turning your phone off and sliding it down the table. I mean, we are putting on time blocks. We are. are using stay focused on our computers. We are giving our phone to our friend to watch it and hold us accountable. If you can't self-impose boundaries to do with social media or whatever it is, adopt tactics that make that boundary or removal of distractions external. Remember, if you're going to do something, don't do it 50% because that's just going to make it feel like you've been doing it for longer. It's going to take more time. When your effort has only been 50%, like when you're multitasking and watching TV while you study or.
我指的移除干扰可不是把手机关机然后顺手往桌子下一扔。我的意思是，我们在设置时间块。我们在电脑上使用“保持专注”（Stay Focused）软件。我们把手机交给朋友让他们帮我们监督并承担责任。如果你无法为社交媒体或其他任何事情自我设定界限，那就采用能将这种界限或对干扰的移除外化的策略。记住，如果你要做一件事，就不要只做50%，因为那只会让你觉得你已经做了更长时间，会耗费更多精力。当你的努力只有50%时，就像你一边学习一边多任务处理看电视，或者
or you're scrolling TikTok whilst you're trying to pay your bills or listen to your lecture, whilst you're listening to a podcast whilst trying to focus on a work deadline. You might think that your brain can process those two things at once, but it can't. We work better when we are more productive when we are 100% focused on one thing. And it will also make the time go by faster. We will get things done quicker and to a higher quality. So distractions, remove them. You will thank yourself later, even if it means to price.
你在试图付账单、听讲座、听播客的同时刷着TikTok，却又想集中精力完成工作截止日期。你可能觉得你的大脑可以同时处理这两件事，但其实不能。当我们百分之百专注于一件事时，我们的工作效率会更高。这也会让时间过得更快。我们会更快、更高质量地完成任务。所以，干扰，请移除它们。事后你会感谢自己的，哪怕这意味着要付出一点代价。
yourself from something you really want to do in the moment. So I hope this episode has helped you from one procrastinator to another. I use all those tips that actually they're really, really effective and I think it's all about minimizing the stress response, meaning that you get things done, you're not always rushing towards that deadline. And you feel less shame, you feel less guilt, you feel better about yourself because you're actually able to do the things that you know are contributing towards your goals and your dreams. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I hope that it has given you something to think about. As always, if you enjoyed this episode and you have a friend who may also be a fellow chronic procrastinator,
让自己不去碰当下非常想做的事。所以我希望这一集能对你有所帮助，来自一个拖延者对另一个拖延者的肺腑之言。我用过所有这些技巧，它们确实非常非常有效，我认为关键全在于尽量减少应激反应，这意味着你能够完成任务，而不是总在火烧眉毛地赶截止日期。你会减少羞愧感，减少负罪感，对自己的感觉更好，因为你实际上能够去做那些你知道对你的目标和梦想有所贡献的事情。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。希望它能带给你一些思考。一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，并且你身边也有朋友是个慢性拖延者，
please feel free to share it with them. If you have an episode suggestion, any feedback, any comments, please feel free to follow us at That Psychology Podcast and shoot me a DM. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. So we'll see you then. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
请随时分享给他们。如果你有节目建议、任何反馈或评论，请随时关注我们的That Psychology Podcast并给我发私信。一如既往，我们下周将推出另一期节目，到时候见。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧意志、健身以及在这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts收听《2%》，也就是数字2%。
or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或您获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如在80年代谈论此事的马克·拉蒙特·希尔。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
您正在收听由您最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都实在不安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。多少男人随身穿着一身铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。请在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节季的推进，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证由真人创作。本集目前尚无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。